If you've ever worked in a corporate
setting before,
corporate jargon is a familiar,
hated fact of life.
Stuff like this can be pretty
frustrating.
I will.
Company has a new strategic initiative
to increase market penetration,
maximize brand loyalty.
It's easy to wonder if there isn't a
simpler way to communicate at work and
it seems like the higher up in the
corporate ladder you go the worst the
jargon gets.
Managers are perhaps the most notorious
for this,
and I'm not criticizing technical
jargon,
which is necessary to describe specific
details in every industry and
criticizing fluff jargon,
corporate speak,
the kind of vague lexicon that makes up
so much of office working life.
It isn't just inefficient.
It allows for confusion and corruption
to hide in plain sight.
Look,
there are valid reasons to say this,
keep things high level and then go after
the low hanging fruit,
but there aren't that many reasons.
Sometimes it's to soften bad news.
We're restructuring and optimizing
capital.
Location sounds a lot better than we're
firing people.
You're a great candidate with a lot of
exciting prospects is a better intro to
a job rejection letter.
Then the truth,
you weren't qualified enough.
Other times it's to sound more
professional.
Let's double down on our 80 20
operations sounds a lot more respectable
than let's do more of the stuff that
makes us money.
These are all legitimate ways to use
corporate jargon,
but mashed together too much corporate
speak and it can render speech and
writing all but incomprehensible.
In fact,
as a testament to this,
Andrew Davidson made a corporate lingo
generator online that spits out
professional sounding gibberish.
For example,
we have robust networks of strategic
assets that we own or have contractual
access to,
which gives us greater flexibility and
speed to reliably deliver widespread
logistical solutions.
We have metamorphosed from an asset
based pipeline and power generating
company to a marketing and logistic
company whose biggest assets are.
It's well established business approach
and innovative people and this is
exactly where corporate lingo and jargon
has a dark side.
It allows people to hide things in plain
sight without anyone noticing.
As I read that randomly generated
statement full of jargon in your eyes,
probably glazed over a little.
You probably didn't pay that close of
attention,
and that's exactly what the people
writing or saying these things want or
expect.
They're designed that way.
In fact,
what I just read wasn't from Andrew
Davidson sites at all.
It was jeff skillings final letter to
the Enron shareholders,
reassuring them that everything was
fine.
You know,
right before it went under as one of the
most blatant and fraudulent companies of
the decade,
and it isn't just using business.
In this clip,
Jack a off and infamous lobbyist in
Washington reflects on some of the
tricks of language he used to get things
done for his clients.
What we did was we crafted language that
was so obscure,
so confusing,
so uninformative,
but so precise to change the u s k
here's what you tried to get tacked onto
this reform bill.
Yeah.
Public law 100 dash 89 is amended by
striking section two oh seven Perrin one
o one step period six six eight comma
six seven to close parenth right now.
Isn't that obvious what that means?
Ah,
so that's,
you tried
to get inserted.
Yes.
And that was going to provide for
casino?
Yes,
and who on earth is going to know that
no one except the chairman of the
committees and it was deliberately
written like that.
Precisely.
That's what's so interesting about this.
The word choice is precise.
The meaning intentionally vague.
Sometimes pages of documents are
dedicated to hiding one message within
the white noise of platitudes.
That's the old,
you didn't read the fine print trope in
movies like the social network and it's
how people get Zuckerberg.
Interestingly,
the noise of corporate jargon is
measurable.
In 1946 a man named Dr Rudolph Flesch
designed a formula to calculate how
easily understood something is.
It's called the flesch readability
score.
The higher the score,
the easier to read and comprehend.
The lower the score,
the more difficult it is.
Just a few landmarks to think about.
Newspaper Comic scored at 93 sports
illustrated at 63 the Wall Street
Journal 43 and the irs tax code.
The holy book of confusing corporate
jargon comes in at an impressive
negative six.
Now.
Obviously there are complex ideas that
can never be expressed within 90 plus
readability score,
but most complex ideas can be expressed
in the 30 to 50 range,
which is considered to be difficult
reading below 30 the flesh formula
considers the document to be very
confusing.
Now let's get back to corruption in the
book.
Why business people speak like idiots.
The authors use this flesch readability
test to analyze the shareholder letters
from ceos at the turn of the century.
They analyze a set of well respected
companies and a set of companies that
have been riddled with scandal.
As it turns out,
the admired companies all have letters
in the 40 range of readability.
While the companies that had scandals
all had much more confusing letters
coming in at the 20s and below,
and that's because the companies were
scandals have every incentive to be very
confusing and used vague jargon to do
it.
While a company that has legitimate
business practices has every reason to
be forthcoming,
okay.
Now,
obviously not all confusing jargon is
meant to hide corruption,
but when there is corruption to hide
corporate language is a great way to do
it.
You can say a lot without saying
anything at all or say everything while
making it sound like nothing.
So let's stop circumventing the normally
understood value added lexicon with
derivative proxies and instead talk
normal.
By the way,
if you're interested,
there's a political movement called the
plain language movement who have voiced
a lot of the concerns that you heard in
this video.
You can check out their website in the
description below.
Oh.